et
[Musique]
vous voulez être la première à déguster
notre fameuse purée de tomates à
tartiner alors prenez un bout de pain et
déguster mais attention car certaines
personnes deviennent folles quand elle
en mange
vous devez vous contrôlez si vous
rencontrez quelqu'un que vous voulez
séduire vous mettez un peu de cette
curée dans son plat et l'affairé est
dans le sac
[Musique]
je suis un mélange de juifs de mexicains
d'américains qui vit en amérique et
essaye de faire travailler ensemble des
juifs et des arabes
j'ai essayé de comprendre comment
l'économie pouvait influencer leur
conflit tout le monde me disait que
j'étais un rêveur alors j'ai décidé
d'aller expérimenté ça sur le terrain
[Musique]
c'est de la pâte à tartiner se fait en
israël pour promouvoir la paix grâce au
business israéliens jordaniens
palestiniens et turcs travaillent
tension pour promouvoir la paix par le
travail j'ai lu de nombreux ouvrages
théoriques sur la manière d'utiliser
l'économie pour résoudre le conflit
israélo-palestinien et j'ai décidé de
partir au moyen-orient' pour étudier la
question sur place en 1994
me daniel houlette ce qui à leurs jeunes
étudiants décident de trouver une
entreprise capable de réunir israéliens
et palestiniens son idée la purée de
tomate
un produit phare en israël élaboré dans
cette usine paris ol benech grâce à
daniel you elle va désormais axer son
entreprise sur un partenariat avec ses
voisins arabes
[Musique]
voici notre première production avec
daniel louvet ski c'est une pâte de
tomate à tartiner vous pouvez y voir un
personnage juif et un arabe se sont
moche et ali ils sont réunis grâce au
business
on a démarré notre entreprise en 1990 et
vous voyez ici tous les produits que
l'on a créé il y en a plus de 400
élaboré pendant ces vingt dernières
années l'entreprise pour la paix est
lancé le new york times fait de daniel
loubinski l'homme de la paix en israël
fait à manger et pas la guerre plus
qu'un slogan laventure commencent les
arabes et les juifs font du commerce
ensemble depuis la nuit des temps mais
c'est la première fois qu'en faisant du
business on essaye de promouvoir la paix
au tpi ce résultat dans cette usine tous
les produits utilisés pour faire la
fameuse pâte à tartiner 100% végétale
proviennent de pays musulmans
tenez regardez dans ces boîtes comme
vous pouvez le voir on a des tomates
séchées qui proviennent de turquie toqué
la première fois que j'ai partagé cette
idée avec joël en israël il a adhéré
immédiatement au lieu d'importer les
bocaux du portugal
ils pouvaient les importés d'égypte au
lieu d'importer les tomates et cali on
pouvait les faire venir de turquie le
basilic et les olives serait bien plus
frais s'ils provenaient des fermiers
palestiniens
on a essayé de trouver des accords qui
était compatible avec ses intérêts
économiques
et c'est la clé de notre modèle qui doit
associer ce même niveau les intérêts
sociaux et économiques
l'entreprise pour la paix est un succès
elle affiche un chiffre d'affaires de 30
millions de dollars et ce malgré les
obstacles et le durcissement politique
de la région j'employais ici 35
palestiniens parfois quand j'arrivais à
l' usine il n'était pas là et ça juste
parce qu'il s'était passé quelque chose
dans les territoires les routes étaient
bloquées et j'ai été forcé de fermer
l'usiné pendant plusieurs jours c'est
dur de travailler dans ces conditions
mais on continue quand même
alors pour garder le contact avec ses
partenaires
joël travail avec annie un arabe
israélien producteur d'huile d'olive
dans son usine
les employés sont arabes pour la plupart
palestiniens ce sont eux qui fournissent
l'huile d'olive nécessaires à la
fabrication de la purée de tomate
fabriqué à tel aviv est vendu dans tous
les états unis
je pense que c'est très important qu'il
y ait un développement entre le business
dans les pays arabes et le business qui
se fait du côté juif
nous achetons des olives d'exploitation
juive au genre du kibboutz qui se
trouvent dans la région nous en achetons
aussi aux exploitations arabes se situe
à l'intérieur de l'état d'israël tout
comme aux agriculteurs qui travaillent
en palestine
c'est un grand mélange c'est pourquoi on
parle de cette huile comme de l'huile de
la paix des réparations et de la
réconciliation dans la région
j'ai pas à l'actionner tiens toi prêt
cette année ouvre bien tes poches parce
que la récolte est très bonne on va tous
en profiter j'ai besoin de 200 tonnes
200 tonnes d'olives à ne sont pas encore
prêtes mais je peux fournir 100 tonnes
d'huile il est comment le marché en
israël cette année ça s'est renforcée
c'est très bien et les prix abou ali
propriétaire d'une oliveraie en
palestine travaille depuis dix ans avec
israël il étendit fervent défenseur du
business pour la paix un grand nombre
d'israéliens qui sont bien et que nous
respectons nous les respectons parce
qu'ils ont mal pour nous ils nous
soutiennent dans nos difficultés
ceux là ont tout notre respect
[Musique]
l'économie aide à humaniser les
relations entre les peuples
c'est une pièce du puzzle mais il faut
de nombreuses pièces pour résoudre un
puzzle comme celui là ce n'est pas un
conflit ingérable comme certains le
disent mais c'est certainement un
conflit bien difficile à résoudre
alors j'ai commencé à réfléchir la
manière dont vous pouvez réunir les
différentes pièces et j'ai créé wang
avec l'argent des sauces tomate en 2002
daniélou bête ce qui fonde one voice son
idée m la société civile au service de
la paix ou un chevreuil se réunit
israéliens et palestiniens afin qu'ils
élaborent ensemble un nouveau projet
pour l'avenir de leurs deux pays
comment imaginez-vous israël en 2018
comment voyez vous son économie la
situation internationale les relations
avec les arabes
pour vous est-ce que la situation va
changer ou est-ce que l'on va rester
bloqué l'équipe de one voice travaille à
sensibiliser la population aux
différentes possibilités de paix leur
grand projet filmer des milliers de
témoignages de la population civile
israélienne et palestinienne pour les
projeter sur grand écran devant les
parlements des deux pays
du côté israélien je crois que les
colons qui vivent dans les territoires
doivent se retirer est relogé ailleurs
du côté palestinien ils doivent
apprendre à se construire une identité
nationale qui ne soit plus uniquement
basée sur le rejet d'israël
ils doivent travailler sur leurs
structures économiques et sociales je
crois que ces centrales pour aboutir à
une solution pour les deux états
en huit ans one voice a su s'imposer
dans les milieux civils et politiques et
obtenir le soutien actif de nombreuses
personnalités l'argent des sauces tomate
au service de la paix un modèle qui est
en train de faire ses preuves
notre vision pour le futur c'est de
prouver que notre modèle peut se
développer dans d'autres régions du
monde
on veut réunir des gens dans des pays
comme le liberia où des femmes
musulmanes et chrétiennes pourrons
travailler ensemble
pareil au kenya ou dans d'autres régions
du monde
le travail occupe une place tellement
importante dans nos vies nous alors on
doit l'utiliser pour apprendre à vivre
ensemble et améliorer notre humanité
[Musique]